sun's gone bad people and animals are
melting everywhere the world is coming
to an end and there's nothing i could do
about it will i be able to find food
while i'll be able to defeat or avoid
the horrific flesh monsters all around
me or the desperate and hungry survivors
left in this terrible new world keep
watching and find out can i survive 100
days in scp-001 when day breaks hey
folks it's your boy kyle you probably
know me more for gaming videos than
post-apocalyptic vlogs but hey i'm a
versatile guy and i think i might go
insane from the fear if i don't talk to
somebody about all this craziness if
you're live and seeing this right now
well congratulations you're probably
doing a lot better than most people here
if you call them people now but if
you're seeing this a few years in the
future like i don't know you woke up
from a 10-year coma like rick from the
walking dead and you're wondering what
the hell happened to planet earth this
video is probably going to answer a lot
of your questions first things first
whatever you do you've got to stay away
from the sun it touches you for even a
second you're dead or worse welcome to
day one of the end of the world for all
of you who are still in a solid state of
matter you're probably wondering how i'm
still alive too chances are it's for the
exact same reason you are sheer dumb
luck i was down here my gaming basement
when day broke just level grinding when
my tv got taken over by those scp
foundation people telling us that the
sun's gone evil for whatever reason and
now we've all got to stay inside hell if
i was up there making myself a sandwich
or grabbing another can of mountain dew
i'd be a freaking puddle right now it's
funny my mom always told me spending all
day indoors was bad for me
i'll have to mention that to her if
she's alive point is the world has gone
to hell in a hand basket and now i've
got only one objective survive i'm going
to see if i can survive the horrifying
post-apocalyptic world of when day
breaks for this first day i'm just going
to hunker down i kind of hope this is
just a dream day two all right i'm up
and at them baby
sadly i can now report that this isn't a
dream this really is our horrible new
reality it's the sun's world and we're
just living in it i've been spending the
last several hours just waiting for
nightfall outside against all odds the
internet and the power grid haven't gone
down yet guess what's ever wrong with
the sun only affects people and animals
not objects thank heaven for small
mercies right people on twitter have
been live posting their situations out
there sharing advice on how we might all
be able to stay out of the sun and
survive this whole crazy thing and hey
unless they're dead or full of hot air
maybe those scp foundation people know
something about what's going on here if
we really can get to their buildings
maybe we can figure out how to reverse
all this mess
maybe for now i'm just gonna focus on
staying alive hopefully night hit soon i
really need to use the bathroom oh boy
it's day three and new issues are
starting to pop up i've been heading
upstairs to go to the bathroom but while
i don't want to be crude i'm running low
on toilet paper and it's um starting to
become a problem i ran out of my last
roll a few days ago and now i'm starting
to go to my bookshelves i have a few
newspapers left that i tore up and used
for toilet paper first
they weren't exactly comfortable but hey
you need to make do but without toilet
paper and without newspapers i need to
figure out what my favorite and least
favorite books are i'm starting with the
prefaces of all the books seeing as i
don't generally need to reread them you
know they're expendable you know a lot
of these books i haven't read since i
was like 15. so maybe those will be the
ones i can't make up my mind on whether
i'm gonna use the harry potter books or
the percy jackson and the olympian books
first uh let me know what you think in
the comments i guess i need to go to the
bathroom day four and now i'm trying to
figure out how to pass the time as you
already know i'm an avowed lifelong
gamer so while the electricity and the
internet still work i'm gonna keep
gaming to pass the time and keep my all
too precious sanity i still have no
intention of going out there even at
night but it's left me feeling kind of
stir crazy i want to walk around the
city again i want to go for a drive and
feel the breeze in my hair but seeing as
i can't do that without experiencing a
truly horrifying transformation i've
been spending a lot of time on gta 5
online yes we'll never get gta 6 now
what a bummer still these last few days
it's felt more like los santos has been
my home than where i actually live there
were even a few other people on the
server i don't know about you but i take
some comfort in that hey folks i'm back
thankfully welcome to day five we've
still got electricity thankfully hence
why you can still see this i haven't
heard anything from my family and i
don't want to assume the worst but yeah
it's probably just best not to think
about it i've been heading up and
downstairs to grab more food at night
you're probably wondering but kyle why
don't you bring it all downstairs to
save going up all together which i'd say
i don't have a fridge downstairs
smart ass but i'm starting to realize
food is gonna be a real issue here it's
kind of stupid now that i think about it
and all the zombie movies and tv shows i
used to watch it was all bullets and
baseball bats killing your way through
all those undead freaks and worrying
about the rest later yes they don't want
you to think about how you're only gonna
ever be a couple weeks away from
starvation kind of ruins the badass
post-apocalyptic power fantasy i only
have a couple days worth of food left
here and after that i'm gonna need to go
out and search for more or i'm gonna
need to relocate i don't feel
comfortable here anymore you know early
on i thought when you got exposed to the
sunlight it just killed you but no it's
worse you keep living you're just
changed into one of those
things these last few days i've looked
out the windows when i've come up at
night for food i i see them sometimes
slithering in the yard or down the
street these things that used to be
people i wonder if they're people that i
knew once before all this and i tried to
shove the thought out of my mind
freaking myself out about all this
doesn't oh i know that much just keep
thinking about how they move this like
weird kind of purpose like they're
searching for something but what could
they be searching for i'm just gonna go
and get more food we'll speak again soon
stay safe whoever you are
welcome to day six it's night time now
and i'm heading out for the first time i
keep seeing these weird slimy creatures
everywhere and they make me kind of sick
to look at them but i try my best to
just keep moving i'm on a mission
tonight i'm going to go to the local
supermarket and check to see if there's
still food there while also grabbing
myself a quick snack i'm going to keep
this one brief i don't want to do a full
shopping spree tonight it's already too
late just need to know the food is there
i decided earlier in the night if i
survive this thing and the getting is
good at the bargain mart i'll make my
way back tomorrow for something a little
more you know substantial after all the
fewer trips i make out the safer i'm
likely to be by the time i made it to
the supermarket though while i was
practically a nervous wreck from the
fear of turning into one of those things
i made an amazing discovery while the
windows were broken and the floor was a
mess most of the food was still there
day seven or should i say night seven
galvanized by my success from the
previous days i decided to come back to
the supermarket with a shopping cart i
wanted to get enough food for at least a
week so i wouldn't need to come back out
again hey maybe i'm not so bad at this
whole apocalypse thing after all i
grabbed plenty of canned food from the
supermarket most of the perishables had
already gone moldy by the time i showed
up so fresh fruit was out of the
question suddenly i started getting
scared about the thought of scurvy but
pushed it quickly from my mind i'd
crossed that bridge when i got to it hey
hey it's day eight and i'm still kicking
that's gotta count for something right i
started taking more trips out at night
time just to stretch my legs and keep
the blood flowing when the slithering
things that were once people pass me i
just make myself scarce and hide in the
shadows you know i i hear them muttering
sometimes and like this melted voice or
voices it's unsettling but it's amazing
what you'll get used to in just over a
week it's here to see all these streets
without people in them i know that i
should probably just stay inside but i i
really can't i don't know if this will
ever just stop and if it doesn't i i
don't want to spend my last days cooped
up in my own basement
day 9. you know there are some benefits
to being in the post apocalypse to ever
so slightly offset all the utterly
crushing downsides while during the day
we're all prisoners of the sun in our
own homes at night we can do whatever
the hell we want i took a baseball bat
that i keep in my closet and went to the
local furniture store i smashed up every
single vase and all the windows like one
of those rage rooms because nobody could
stop me then afterwards i went straight
to the local computer and gaming store
and took all the alienware tech i could
physically carry you know there's no
value in money anymore if you want
something you can just go and take it
every cloud has a silver lining day 10
more gta 5 today i decided to get on my
headset and speak to a few others who
were still around and on the servers you
know it was so nice to speak to other
human beings for once they came from all
over the world and were dealing with the
same evil sun insanity as me you have no
idea how incredibly valuable it is to
find people to talk to in a time like
this the other players had plenty of
theories as to why all this had happened
some thought it was some kind of mutant
solar flare they'd remembered reading
about on some conspiracy form back in
the day others speculated it was the
result of some weapon created by the us
or russian or chinese military that had
gone wrong one person said that maybe it
was a punishment from god
maybe on some level we all deserved it
you know things got pretty quiet after
that day 11. i've been having the most
terrible nightmares lately it's probably
just a product of all the stress i've
been under lately but in the nightmares
i'm running down a dark street being
chased by those flesh creatures i'm
moving fast but they're moving way
faster they're whispering to me but i
can't make out anything they're saying
this morning which is to say
evening i woke up screaming and drenched
in sweat i can't really explain why but
i feel like something terrible is gonna
happen soon okay okay i'm alive that's
enough isn't it and if you're watching
this i assume you're live too
congratulations welcome to the nightmare
space between day 11 and day 27. sorry
that i haven't been in contact for so
long as you can see i'm not at home
anymore you couldn't pay me to go back
there
not that money is worth anything anymore
a lot's happened since i last made one
of these and i wish i could tell you any
of it was good hell i wish i could
forget it all but the things i've seen
and heard i don't think they're ever
gonna leave my head no matter what i do
i thought about making another entry now
and then but i always found a reason to
put it off it's remarkable how your
other priorities fall away when you're
just thinking about where your next meal
is coming from it just kind of puts
everything into perspective of course
during my travels i saw more of those
freaks slithering around sorry sorry i i
know i shouldn't call them that it's
kind of a coping mechanism you know it
all gets a lot harder when you have to
think of them as
ex-people that's another thing all these
goofy zombie shows got wrong it's a lot
harder to separate what they were from
what they are now especially when you
know these were your friends your
neighbors your
well i can't avoid talking about it
forever can i i stuffed my backpack with
whatever i could grab and left my home
two nights ago it wasn't just because i
was going stir crazy back there though i
admit that didn't exactly help it was
what happened there i just came back
from a food run put most of it in the
fridge then retired back down into the
basement to enjoy a late night snack and
do a little gaming to keep myself sane
i've been doing everything i could to
reverse my circadian rhythms and sleep
during the day just so i could be fully
operational during the 12-hour period
that going outside wouldn't melt me but
just like all those stories they told us
when we were kids there are monsters out
there at night and they are looking for
us when i first heard the sound i was i
wondered if it was something in game or
maybe dripping from a leaky pipe and now
it was too close to be fake and too
viscous to be watered that's when i
looked at the door and saw this awful
pink slime slithering its way underneath
my door it was one of those things those
ex people trying to get in that'd be bad
enough but then it started talking to me
kyle
my darling
why are you all cooped up down here
it isn't healthy
you ought to come outside sweetie
get some sun
my
it was my mom well it used to be i guess
she wanted to come over and visit me
needless to say i got out of there and
i've got no intention of going back that
place is dead to me now i don't even
want to think about that voice ever
again both her and so
not her so now i'm on the move i guess
i'll speak to you again when i stop stay
safe out there day 28 i decided it was
best to make my way out of town towards
the fringes the day first broke the
people who were in the most densely
populated areas were the first to go
that's why i decided to hole up in a gas
station last night just to avoid the sun
but during the night people came not
ex-people actual people they showed up
in a jeep outside the building refueled
and then came in they were wearing black
cobbled together outfits and hockey
masks they were all either carrying
baths or axes too you can probably
understand why i didn't decide to
introduce myself when they busted their
way in i concealed myself in a broom
closet while they searched around it was
nerve shredding i'd never been more
thankful in my life when they've left
day 29 coming up on a month of this
madness after the incident at the gas
station i realized i needed some kind of
defense it's not just the sun and those
creatures i need to worry about just
like the old world people could be
dangerous here too that's why i snuck
into a gun store in the dead of night
some of it had been looted but much like
the supermarket near my house there was
plenty still here the walls were covered
in all manner of rifles shotguns and
even submachine guns i heard somewhere
that revolvers are more reliable and
easy to maintain than other types so
since i'm a gun novice i grabbed a
revolver and stuffed my pockets with as
many bullets as i could carry let's hope
i never have to use any of them day 30.
do i get to call this a month of
survival i mean if we're talking
february i'd be a month in already
what a horribly dubious honor that is i
saw something disgusting last night and
i thought i'd share it just to get it
off my mind last night as i was moving
through the wilderness i saw a group of
other survivors gathered around a
campfire i remained scarce but
approached just to see what was going on
still carrying my revolver just to be
safe but the people around the campfire
were eating something and when i saw
what they were eating i
swear to god i almost threw up they were
chopping up one of the x people hooking
the parts over the fire and eating it
day 31 a month by anyone's definition
ever since seeing those others eating
one of the ex people i've had trouble
eating even normal food myself my
stomach aches and my throat burns
god i feel so weak i keep laying down
and resting i know i need to eat soon if
i want to survive to day 32 but every
time i think about eating i think about
the gooey flesh of the ex-people
sometimes i wish i hadn't survived this
long i'll eat soon i just need to sleep
first day 32 243 if you live this long
you really ought to be proud of yourself
i've seen thousands of those slimy ex
people and there's probably millions
more out there well maybe even billions
if we're being honest with ourselves
here am i just talking into the void
here is there even anyone else out there
who's human enough to watch this stuff
maybe i just need to keep thinking about
posterity on the off chance that the
world ever gets better and we reach some
time where children are born again and
all this fades from human memory you'll
still have these stupid pointless little
videos to remember how awful all this
was that way at least i can make myself
believe this all had some kind of i
don't know point so what's happened with
me not much still moving at night
surviving hiding in closets and
underground parking complexes during
daylight down to uh my last few cans so
i'm hoping to hit a supermarket soon god
what a ridiculous way to go starving in
this new world with so many new
interesting ways to die with the x
people things have been a little more
eventful there used to be one blob to a
person but they've started
joining up that's the best way i can put
it things that used to be people and
animals are starting to melt together
getting bigger and bigger they've never
been aggressive but i think it's best to
stay out of their way whatever all this
is about i am streetwise enough to know
that it can't be anything good i'll just
keep moving and i hope you can do the
same whoever the hell you are hopefully
the next time i check in with you it's
with better news than
this day 44. i saw a shootout on the
road last night the people who are left
the ones who are still indeed people are
becoming less human something about
situations like this this sustained
stress and pain and hopelessness it
weighs on you there are no rules in the
post-apocalypse the only thing that can
stop you from doing anything is a bullet
to the head five or six people last
night as afraid and desperate and hungry
as me gunned each other down they did
this for reasons i will never understand
even if i wanted to because there are no
survivors left to tell the tale what a
funny world we live in day 45 i sleep
when i can it's surreal i remember when
i feared the dark and loved bright sunny
days even all this time in i still don't
think i'm used to the switch bean flip
i've been having awful dreams again i'm
still running in them with a deep red
sun shining up in the sky
being chased by a mountain of flesh the
size of mount everest and swallowing up
the city behind me and it keeps getting
closer no matter how fast i go i just i
can't escape it'll get me eventually
something terrible is going to happen
soon i just know it day 46. i shot a man
today i don't know if he survived
i hope he lived we encountered each
other inside an abandoned building i i
think we spooked each other and didn't
have any time to ask if we were friends
or foes we were too afraid either way we
both drew our weapons and i was faster
than he was when my revolver discharged
and he collapsed i ran off someone would
come up in a few hours and i just needed
to find another place to hide
what the hell have i become i don't know
how things could get any worse than this
not to self in the future don't even
dare to think how could things get any
worse because if i've learned anything
since this whole nightmare started that
is never a rhetorical question welcome
to the space between day 47 and day 64.
if you're still alive and watching this
i am so sorry so i've got good news and
i've got bad news i'll give you the good
news first i've seen more people who
haven't been changed yet and the bad
news last time i saw them they were
being dragged out into the light kicking
and screaming in the tendrils of one of
those horrible flesh monsters i was
telling you about last time they've
gotten a lot bigger now and when i told
you they weren't aggressive well um
yeah i spoke a little too soon i can't
just sleep during the day like i used to
these monsters and that's what they are
now they're monsters not people anymore
they patrol they hunt they actively
enter buildings searching for hiding
places searching for people they can
drag out into the light i've seen it
with my own two eyes the second they're
out they'll just start melting and
fusing with the mass making it even
bigger adding another voice to the
chorus and i hate myself because every
time i've seen it happen all i can think
is thank god that's not me
god i wish i could do something to help
to save them that's not the world we
live in the second they touch the light
it is already over i wouldn't be helping
anyone by adding my flesh to one of
those things i don't want them using my
body to get to other people there's only
one thing i can do now keep moving at
night stay hidden get away from
population centers i've realized where i
need to go now i've still got a distant
memory of those broadcasts in the
earlier days of the event the scp
foundation
i noted down coordinates to the nearest
facility they had on the books and if
i'm honest nearest is only a relative
term because at this rate it's gonna
take me an eternity to get there but
it'll be worth it in the end when i get
there it'd all be worth it if i can at
least get some answers at least know why
the world turned into this hell those
scp folks seem better prepared for this
than anyone so even if they can't fix
this they've at least got to have
answers right somebody needs to have
answers i really want to believe that
when the sun goes down i'll start moving
again if you're watching this wish me
luck i don't have much food left i'll do
what i can
yeah hey
i realize i'm not looking great right
now but trust me you should see the
other guy day
65 today 86. never thought i would make
it this far but hey life's just full of
surprises before you ask and i mean why
would you ask it's not like i can hear
you it wasn't one of the monsters that
did this to me it was another person
just like me desperate hungry afraid the
one difference between me and them was
the fact that they had a handgun and i
didn't they asked for all the food i had
and when i wasn't exactly forthcoming
they decided to shoot me and steal the
last of my food while i lay bleeding on
the ground oh well okay that's not
entirely fair they did leave me with one
protein bar which i had to cave and eat
a couple days ago
since then i've just been foraging with
little food i can from plants along the
way during my nighttime walks but
it isn't much and my wound is giving me
grief i sure hope they've got doctors at
this scp foundation or otherwise
i may be
even more out of luck than i thought
here's the good news for you since i
know how much you love that i'm not far
off of the foundation site now even in
this state i'm probably only a couple
weeks away i think maybe i can will
myself to live that long at least
if i can get some answers just
before i die then i can be happy and
sometimes folks that's all you can ask
for
final stretch let's hope i see you again
on the other end stacey i'm here i'm
here the scp foundation on day 100 but
i don't understand where is everybody
hello is anybody there god damn it why
is nobody here i i don't understand they
were meant to have the answers they were
meant to know what was going on here but
they're all gone too it isn't fair it
isn't fair
is this it is it all just over the end
of the freaking world as we know it
isn't fair
it is
wait are those footsteps hello yes hello
i'm over here who's there oh my god what
the hell is that thing
no
no get away from me oh god
disgusting
now go check out when daybreak's scp-096
and when day breaks
scp-049 for more tales from the
nightmarish universe of
scp-001 when day breaks